[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
société un nouveau numéro ici à
l'auditorium de la batterie à guyancourt
à l'occasion de la conférence première
année et premier lien en compagnie de
catherine dolto
[Musique]
c'est toujours intéressant de pouvoir
profiter de conférences d'une personne
aussi renommées
en concernant les petits enfants
françoise dolto est assez connu et je
pense que voilà catherine dolto du coup
reprend les rênes et ils portent des
messages assez positif en termes
d'éducation
je suis venu assister à cette conférence
parce que je connais catherine dolto
en tant qu'enseignante avec les livres
qu'elle écrit à destination des enfants
et puis aussi depuis très longtemps
puisque c'était quand j'étais enceinte
et qu'elle avait parlé beaucoup de la
méthode de l'ap tonomy à l'époque
c'était complètement expérimental et ça
a été absolument génial les relations
qu'on a pu avoir avec le bébé qu'on
attendait tous les deux moi même on m'a
expliqué comment la prochaine à mal du
ventre et comment faire bouger l'enfant
et toi que ça c'était très important que
le père participe
j'ai deux enfants en bas âge 4 ans et
quinze mois et je viens justement pour
avoir quelques pistes qui peuvent aider
quand
on éduque ses enfants c'est de le faire
le plus en douceur possible
bonjour catry palau vous êtes médecin
est apte au thérapeute vous êtes la
fille de françoise dolto et boris dolto
psychanalyste et pédiatres qui a été
très connu dans notre pays une célébrité
qu'elle doit à ses ouvrages et les
émissions radio auquel elle participe et
notamment l'émission de radio lorsque
l'enfant paraît sur france inter vous
l'aidiez pour cette émission
votre mère sensibiliser le public
l'enfant est dès son plus jeune âge est
un sujet à part entière en devenir
il est essentiel de communiquer de
parler vrai avec ses enfants
oui c'est vrai d'ailleurs je vous
signale qu'une bande dessinée va sortir
sur cette émission qui s'appelle longue
dolto c'est cet amusant ce que vous
dites parce que maintenant tous les
neuroscientifiques prouve que ce qu'elle
disait était vrai mais ils oublient dire
qu elle le disait déjà dès 1939 par
exemple qu'il fallait absolument
s'adresser un bébé et qu'il avait
l'entendement sais pas comment mais que
ça faisait sens pour lui parler vrai
prenons un cas concret des parents qui
divorcent
est ce qu'on doit tout dire à l'enfant
on doit tout dire de ce qui le regarde
tous ne le regarde pas l'essentiel c'est
nous ne pouvons plus vivre ensemble ne
nous aimons pas assez pour vivre
ensemble mais nous restons toujours tous
les deux des parents dans ton coeur on
n'est pas séparable des choses comme ça
mais d'aller lui raconter ton père avait
une maîtresse et c'est ça n'a aucun sens
c'est ce qui a été tellement mal compris
et dévoyé c'est que dire la vérité c'est
pas dire tout donc on laisse aux parents
une part de vie privée heureusement vous
animé une conférence première année
premier lien vous partagez est la
méthode d'auto la pédagogique
vous vous attendiez à ce que ce soit
encore d'actualité on peut bien sûr
toute façon actuellement on est en train
de découvrir des choses que non
seulement ma mère mais l'haptonomie que
je pratique mon 10 depuis 60 ans alors
tout d'un coup les gens comme c'est
scientifiquement prouvé
les gens du coup nous écouter nous
regarde un peu plus
c'est donc un héritage
mais nous vous avez fait des
modifications des l'haptonomie ça n'est
pas françoise dolto
c'est frans veldman bon moi j'ai choisi
de patrick analystes et j'ai choisi de
me consacrer à l'apd onomique et la
science de l'affectivité bien sûr que
j'y vais en apportant tout le bagage de
ce que j'ai reçus en travaillant avec ma
mère mais c'est pas du tout d'elle que
ça vient
ce qui me vient d'elle c'est mon
expérience ma connaissance la certitude
du de l'enfant sujet est intelligent et
un certain art de faire avec et tout le
travail haptonomie qu cet autre chose et
ma grande chance c'est d'avoir rencontré
une pratique avec l'haptonomie où je
peux utiliser tout ce que j'ai reçue non
seulement de ma mère mais de mon père
qui était un grand médecin de médecine
physique de rhumes de d'ostéopathie et
cetera de rhumatologie de kinésithérapie
et donc je fais une synthèse de ce que
j'ai reçu de ces deux là dans
l'haptonomie qui est autre chose et donc
vous êtes apte au terrain peu de vous
accompagner les parents lors de la
grossesse et les bébés pendant la
première année de leur vie
on conditionne entre guillemets l'enfant
dès la grossesse lui d'un manque le moc
auditionné cheveux parfums d'accepter
oui parce que maintenant on sait que
l'enfant dans la vie prénatale il est
peureux il est en quête déjà de sens et
de relation donc si on entre en
communication avec lui ça nourrit
l'affectif 1 qui a besoin d'être nourris
comme l'intellect et ça lui permet de
frayer des circuits neuronaux qui sinon
resteraient en friche et ça fait des
enfants qui arrivent avec beaucoup plus
de sécurité de base à leur naissance
et comme je suis psychothérapeute apte
aux psychothérapeutes georges et comme
patient aussi des adolescents des
adultes des gens âgés et je vois les
effets de la vie prénatale et de la
naissance tout au long de la vie tout au
long la trajectoire de vie ce moment
fondateur de l'enracinement dans la vie
prénatale dans les premiers mois de vie
dans l'acte de n'être va influencer
toute la trajectoire sur le plan à la
fois psychique affectif et physique
et justement c'est prouvé et justement
quels sont les effets prouvés
alors les effets prouvés c'est ce sont
des enfants plus calme de tranquille on
très serein qui pleure pas pour un oui
pour un non qui sont souriants qui sont
paisibles et après ça fait un
développement parce qu'il ya un travail
post natale indispensable ça fait des
enfants qui sont beaucoup plus en
confiance beaucoup plus ça fait des gens
qui ont un goût d'être présent au monde
et d'échanger
alors quand je dis prouver c'est qu' il
existe l'épigénétique c'est le fait que
ce qui se passe dans la vie des petits
prénatal mans pendant la naissance et
après va leur faire modifier le
patrimoine génétique qu'ils ont reçue à
la naissance et ça c'est archi prouvé
chez les petits rats chez les humains
partout le traumatisme précoce même le
traumatisme chez le rat mal avant la
conception va influer sur sa descendance
et on sait que pour les enfants c'est la
même chose
donc maintenant on se dit comment se
fait-il qu'on n'est pas ce souci de
prévention en accueillant mieux les
parents avant la naissance en ayant un
grand souci de ce qu'on leur fait vivre
pendant la naissance et dans les
premiers mois de vie puisqu'on sait que
l'enfant va pas utiliser son patrimoine
génétique de la même façon s'il a été
porté par une mère rassurer en sécurité
ont par une mère anxieuse et quelles
seraient les modifications justement
apporter selon vous pour que cet enfant
soit plus en confiance que l'affectif
joue un rôle dans le développement de
l'enfant son éducation et dans le
déploiement du coût de son intelligence
c'est impossible de répondre vite à
cette question le fil rouge c'est la
sécurité affective
c'est à dire que l'être humain sans aide
qui mettent très longtemps à sortir du
nid nous sommes ni dit cole donc l'être
humain et il a un cortex qui fait qu'ils
pensent ou le temps donc l'être humain
se construit dans la dépendance et dans
la peur d'être abandonné tout le temps
donc un cerveau humain ça fonctionne
toujours avec en prob déguise passe
quelque chose je suis en sécurité ou pas
je suis menacé ou pas peur pas peur et
en fonction de ça il va penser
il va créer
il va articuler des idées et c'est donc
la sécurité affective pour une femme
enceinte c'est d'être accueillis de
pouvoir être arrêté si elle est trop
fatigué si elle a mal et c'est d'être
comprise avec tout ce que ça te
particulier sur son milieu de travail de
voir son médecin sa sage femme en ayant
du temps en passant pas une heure et
demie assis sur un petit banc europe et
c est de pouvoir se sentir en confiance
et d'être accompagné par le père de
l'enfant si possible l'enfant est un
être en construction mais il ne peut pas
se développer correctement sans
l'éducation des parents donc sans
l'autorité
quels conseils donnez-vous à des parents
qui ne savent plus trop comment s'y
prendre avec leurs enfants ou l'autorité
par exemple source de conflit là aussi
vous me posez des questions il faudrait
une heure il faut il ya deux choses
il y a toujours fait ressentir à
l'enfant qu'à la fois nous sommes égaux
mais qu'en même temps il ya une
asymétrie est à les grands et les petits
les parents et les enfants donc un
enfant doit être contenue il ya plein de
choses à faire il ya écouter essayait
toujours de comprendre du point de vue
de l'enfant
pourquoi et faire la différence entre
l'agressivité saine qui est la grille
york et cette vie très bien grande
vitalité qui fait qu'un enfant qui va
bien jusqu'à 6 ans ça fait du désordre
du bruit et ça dérange
et comme une fois qu'on a compris ça on
peut pas demander un enfant petit de ne
pas bouger de ne pas faire de bruit au
moins jusqu'à 4 ans ou de d'être capable
de maîtriser cette espèce d'orage
pulsionnel que les méchants appelle des
caprices un qui est une espèce
d'éruptions volcaniques dont il est le
siège il n'a pas jusqu'à quatre ans son
cerveau ne lui permet pas donc essayé de
le raisonner de culpabiliser d'être trop
vivant ben ça fait que cette agressivité
scène ce trop de vies il va leur tournée
soit contre lui soit contre les autres
en vrai agressivité donc c'est tout un
monde et certains enfants justement
montre des signes d'agressivité
morne il frappe il tape comment réagir
quand on est parent mais justement c'est
de comprendre que c'est de la grée dior
c'est à dire la version celle de la
griffe et les enfants souvent mortes
soit parce que on les embrasse trop sur
le visage qui se sentent dévorer soit
dans la phase où ils ont bon goût de
choses qui voudrait dire qu'ils ne
savent pas encore parlé et qui
confondent dévorer l'autre ou bien dire
très fort et le baiser devient morsure
ce n'est jamais mal ou pour faire du mal
qu un enfant mort toutes ces choses à
face parle ça suffit pas d'être né d'un
homme et d'une femme pour se développer
comme un humain il faut être humanisée
c'est à dire que des adultes
bienveillant mais bien contenant nous
permettent de peu à peu être plus fort
que nos forces pulsionnel de mammifères
qui veut renoncer à rien ce soit
l'éducation donc les parents doivent
faire preuve d'autorité mais également
laissé à l'enfant aussi un espace libre
oui d'abord et puis d'abord ne pas les
harceler avec le temps dépêche-toi
dépêche-toi dépêche-toi il faut du temps
pour panser les enfants ont besoin de
temps et donc bien sûr il faut pas
confondre l'autorité et l'autoritarisme
contenir c'est pas la même chose que
cadres et donc contenir ces données de
l'autorité de en rassurant et en étant
respectueux de la personne de l'enfant
mais jamais humiliant et en essayant
toujours de comprendre quel était son
intention
parlons à présent de l'évolution de
l'enfant vers l'adolescence vous parlez
du complexe du homard de ça c'est ma
mère qui a eu pour définir elle la crise
de l'adolescence une métaphore expliqué
dans un ouvrage intitulé paroles pour
adolescents le complexe du homard dont
la particularité est d'être destiné aux
adolescents eux-mêmes
c'était le premier d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que ça a été un énorme succès
personne ne s'adressait aux adolescents
eux-mêmes alors le complexe du homard
c'était jolie métaphore pour dire que
quand on change beaucoup physiquement
les homards il faut qu'ils changent de
carapace donc il
il s'extrait de la leur ce qui en soi
est dangereux certains en meurent et
pendant un certain nombre d'heures ils
attendent que la nouvelle carapace et
durcit à ce moment là ils sont très
vulnérables et il paraît que les congrès
les autres poissons savent que dans ce
moment là le homard et faciles à manger
et les guette et dans la vie d'un
adolescent il ya énormément de combles
et ils sont en particulier dans les
réseaux sociaux les derniers points
avant de clôturer notre entretien vous
animez donc une conférence devant des
parents en majorité justement quel est
le rôle du père et de la mère dans la
bonne évolution d'un enfant vous poser
que des questions il faudrait un temps
fou pour répondre d'abord il faut
toujours se dire que les pères sont pas
des mères avec les maires sont pas des
thés l'enfant a idéalement besoin des
deux c'est très très difficile d'élever
un enfant seule
vraiment je conseille ça à personne bon
et donc le rôle c'est d'humaniser c'est
à dire par exemple quand il ya des
manifestations comme la mort sur le coup
des noms chez nous les humains ont fait
pas ça on parle et c'est s'adresser à
l'enfant en lui parlant le plus vrai
possible des lois des humains les
grandes lois des humains la première
qu'on dit jamais assez souvent c'est
l'interdît de l'inceste qui doit être
dit très tôt puisque les enfants à
partir de 2 ans et demi trois ans on
influent bages et 10 pien et vont
essayer de faire des problèmes dans le
couple
et si jamais un des parents est un peu
dans la séduction où ça n'explique pas
ça tout de suite ça prend des
proportions énormes donc dire la loi
dans le fond ce cadre qu'on a à
transmettre un enfant chacun de notre
place le père et la mère c'est que pour
vivre ensemble le prix que nous payons
nous les mammifères
c'est que personne ne fait ce qu'il veut
quand il veut où il veut quand il veut
comme il veut et que ça il faut
l'accepter
merci catherine dolto d'avoir participé
à sept huit sociétés merci à vous très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]